why have you forsaken me poop gods hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to muddy Heights the poop game I
wish I was joking but when it comes to
matters of poop I am deadly serious this
is actually a game and more unbelievably
people actually requested this of me
like in droves people wanted me to sit
on top of a balcony on a cityscape and
poop on the unsuspecting citizens of the
city below like why would that even be a
thing and yet here we are when I take
upon a poop job I to it with pig when I
take on a poop job I do with the utmost
sincerity and seriousness so I'm going
to strive to be as serious about this
solemn duty as possible as we literally
cause our poop to fly in random
directions because this dumbass up
here's to decided to go up on a roof
when he really needed to go to the
bathroom and for some reason his only
option there's a bush literally right
there his only option in his mind is to
lean over the balcony and literally poop
on the floor
of the world which is also known as the
street so it's so stupid all that guy
does not look happy about a situation
then again if you were a citizen walking
around on your home day probably had a
terrible day before this wife probably
left him kids hate him now he's just
wondering where his life went so wrong
okay let's do it again if you didn't
know there are achievements or what they
call secrets in this game where you can
check out different things that you can
do with your poop and you can send your
poop a fly-in in different directions
you can do different things to get bonus
combo points like get it in the sewer
and then you feel achieve about your
life and you feel happy for what you've
done in the course of your life that led
up to you playing a poop game on the
internet in front of about a million B
stuff it's enough is enough why does
that sign say poop on it the turd
wizards goddamn this can I understand
that poop humor is the foundation of all
comedy oh no yes
run citizens yeah don't fall face-first
into the poop it's definitely not gonna
work out for you oh you sorry sexy crab
so from the money that you earned from
[ __ ] on the common man you can
actually buy more food because there's
one thing that you want to do is order
takeout from the top of a roof where
you're [ __ ] on everyone below but
that's just the way the world works I
guess so I'm going to buy food chili I
forget what that said I don't even know
burger makes your poop greasy making
good slide better cotton candy makes
your poop lighter great why would I want
that big burrito makes you poop larger
larger lighter and slimmer this doesn't
sound like what I want from my boob I
don't want anything from my poop I don't
know yeah I got a thing with my poo yeah
you better run citizens it's the most
horrifying thing you've ever seen in
your life milk gives you the runs your
poop leaves a bigger splatters I don't
know what horrible witch bewitched this
man's bumble and cursed him to
perpetually poop on the citizens of this
city what god damn is just the worst
idea I'm looking at this guy's face and
I can't help it he actually has to go or
if he's just really enraged at the
situation why have you cursed me poop
Lourdes why have you forsaken me poop
gods birdy
I didn't even check what other
achievements that I needed because I
kinda wanna I kinda want to be a
completionist about this game you know
it's such a world
that you really need to respect all of
them you know Jackson Pollock's style
art that's represented across the city I
mean in reality this game is pure art
you are an art hockey excuse me citizens
I'm not trying to hit you I'm trying to
hit the fruit that you want to eat every
day yeah the turd wizards alright more
money for me you know if there was a job
where you earn thousands of dollars
every time you pooped on the citizens
below the world would be drownded
shipped all right over there buddy
you need something seem to be in denial
about what's happening hey just accept
the poop man it's here it's gonna stay I
just want to step into the mind of this
guy for one quick second well the poop
oh I only have a few more pets so um
window cleaner and dump the dump I'm
guessing I need to put my poop into a
dumpster which I see one over there
or a trash can down below cuz there's
some like there's trash cans like right
here I don't know if that's I'm still
proud is everybody proud of me I am NOT
okay is it just need to get it on a lamp
well why am i carrying a splatter with
me I found a bug in your perfect game
otherwise ten out of ten IGN but I just
need window cleaner which I'm assuming
is just me splattering up against
windows ah did I miss oh come on that
was like right on it is this smell I'm
supposed to do sorry sorry I was aiming
for the windows please stop okay all
right I guess all right
oh maybe I'm supposed to poop on the car
windows oh that would make a lot more
sense yeah oh come on it's about the
goddamn sound that they make when they
realize okay so I can't find out how to
do the window cleaner achievement but
frankly I've subjected myself to enough
poop I have taken this as seriously as I
possibly could and I have strove and I
have striven to do as much as I can in
the name of poop games everywhere and
poop art in general I support poop oh
that to the heavens so thank you all so
much for watching I don't have a damn
suggestion for what video you need to
see next but I hope it's cute and not
related to poop at all I eagerly await
the sequel golden rivers for the next
time this guy decides to make a game and
thank you again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
I'm like an indecisive lesbian